all right it is now time for paul's
picks thanks to taylormade productions
for sponsoring this segment summer is in
full swing and entertaining expert paul
zahn is back with us with his must-haves
to keep you glowing and going this
season welcome back thanks for having me
there's a lot going on this time of year
right a lot going on okay whether it's
for your skin or whether you're going
shopping or events
yes yes let's start with skincare
skincare with this wonderful duo from
olay with their niacinamide plus peptide
24. okay so what this is going to do is
going to help with the wrinkles it's
going to help hydrate because it's so
hot and so dry here in las vegas so it's
going to help with that it's going to
help to correct uneven tones and it's
healthier looking skin with 99 pure
niacinamide and you might say paul why
is this in the package because it's a
two pack and if you pop into sam's tub
about one yes if you pop in the sam's
club you get eight dollars off between
now and august seven so that's just one
time application at night put it on put
it on the morning at night get that
hydration going we need it all right
what's next weekend of hydration next up
we have some back to school meals made
easy with smart finals so i love smart
and final it is one trip and that's it
they have everything you need
including this line called sun harvest
which is organic and it's much more cost
effective and they also have a green
line of things like compostable forks
and spoons in detergent and everything
like that so it's better for your wallet
and it's better for mother nature
breakfast is made easy right here with
some granola and some peanut butter nut
clusters we got some peanut butter so
you know one click and that's it if you
go to smartinfinal.com and they have an
app so download the app and you'll love
it smart final makes it easy yes they
make it so easy so easy and what about
this summer drink oh yeah next up we
have absolute so absolute has teamed up
with garcelle bouvier to create this fun
front yard citrus situation here so you
know absolute vodka is a perfect
cocktail for any summer sorry so they've
created this cooler together
inspired by the different flavors so
this is the lime they have grapefruit
they have citron they have a wide
variety of different flavors of coolers
and so not only is it a table but it's
also a cooler so you fill this with ice
and everybody go to the front yard get
together have an absolute cocktail and
really celebrate that's a great backyard
the balcony where can you get that you
can get this at reservebar.com and it's
a great gift too for a summer story
i definitely i agree i agree okay next
up summer shopping summer shopping back
to school back to school the kids are
going back to school well jcpenney has
you covered it's your one stop shop for
all things back to school for the kids
they have a wide variety of items from
classics like this fun denim jacket
right here they have denim pants they
have these cute shoes and they're such
great prices you can go to jcpenney or
jcp.com and they have all they have
husky they have adaptive clothes so it's
really for every kid in every ability
and they have coupons i love a good
coupon at jcpenney.com because hello
everybody's on the budget this time of
year right exactly and back to school
for the kids but also for the parents
too
all right and last but certainly not
least um coffee cocktails love a coffee
cocktail so we have some liquor 43 so
this is the most popular spanish liqueur
in the world it's 43 natural ingredients
and i get a lot of vanilla from it so it
makes a wonderful cocktail called the
carajillo so it's a shot of espresso a
shot of the liqueur 43 and it's
absolutely delicious and we also have a
horchata with liquor 43 that is actually
vegan so it's delicious you can do a fun
little pina colada with that you can
pick these up at total wine or drizzly
has been my best friend the past couple
years you go on drizzly app and they
will deliver it to you you can have
wonderful cocktails you have the best
tips that's why you're the entertaining
expert okay thank you so much paul for
being here thank you these are great